[Music]
hey everybody what's up why is it so
bright over there no because that door's
open though
i had it closed but
i guess pookie pushed it open yeah she's
been hanging around hanging out in there
like hanging out in the laundry basket i
don't know what the deal is today got a
large late start because i had to [ __ ]
with the damn sprinkler system make sure
everything's working good the program's
right
make sure sprinklers are well our
connection the connection crashed when i
first started anyway so i had to start
over all right i've been having a [ __ ]
of a time with this connection today i
don't know what it is um this computer
that computer i'm kind of all kind of
it's everything
yeah i know that's what happens when you
live in the middle of nowhere i guess
well i think it's worse than that you
know i think there's
probably you know there's
just problems in general
yeah
i heard the internet's going down in
certain states in certain regions for a
while just you know
cyber attacks man
cyber attacks
um
okay whatever i don't know yeah but um
yeah so today as we mentioned yesterday
uh we are going to be talking about a
1973 movie that we just ended up
watching at random because it had burnt
reynolds in it we were actually gonna do
cannonball run but we couldn't really
find it anywhere it wasn't 100 at random
they offered it for free
well yeah
i remember that movie when i was a kid
random in the sense that we were just
flipping through the free [ __ ] and said
uh okay
i remember people talking about this
movie when i was a little kid white
lightning how good this movie was this
is like you know seven-year-olds telling
me this
yeah i was probably in mississippi at
the time but uh
we were teenagers later on when
cannonball run cam came out and burt
reynolds was already a damn fixture in
southern culture already well
established
and i had kind of missed his
establishment i i didn't really i just
thought i'd just do a mustache
all right here's dudes dude with a
mustache
but he had a bunch of movies in his past
that kind of built him up
to be kind of like a
southern
superstar
and it was movies like this and this was
a good movie it was real good
for its time for what it was
yeah i didn't remember ever so like i
thought that i had seen this one but
then i was watching it i was kind of
like no i think it was gator that i saw
which was the sequel to this
you know it's like the same character
yeah and that came out in 1976 but i
don't think that i'd ever seen this one
because this was 1973. this has a lot of
the same cast as cannonball run
oh yeah the dude the dude who played uh
what was his name the guy that had the
damn truck
yeah or especially same same cast as
smoking abandoned
no no it wasn't it is that's not that
that guy that you're thinking of that's
not that's not who you're that's not who
that is no looks just like him it's not
though okay no in smoking the bandit
that was jerry reed the country singer
okay and that wasn't him
in that movie he looks just like him i
thought that was the same guy no it's
not okay he's familiar he's familiar
totally different guy when i saw him he
just he looked familiar you know i mean
i i've seen him before what's that guy's
name the blond-haired guy in this i
don't know okay but it's not the same
guy because he's in a bunch of other
movies so it's not the first time i've
seen him but i thought he was the same
guy from smoking event no that was jerry
reid like i said he was famous in music
other than movies he was like a country
singer all right that's it he's the one
that did he spouted down he was all that
okay that was him singing i stand
corrected i thought it was the same guy
nope nope that's a different dude all
right so it's a good movie it's kind of
like
you can see where
a lot of the [ __ ] from smoking the
bandit came from they lifted it from
this movie a lot of it
well i think it i don't even know if it
was so much lifting it was just kind of
like in the 70s this was kind of like a
sub genre that was popular like you kind
of had your southern
uh
movies with car chases and moonshining
and [ __ ] like that and bootlegging and
that kind of stuff and there was just
kind of like a whole because even in you
know the exploitation cinema circuit
there were all those kind of
you know red and exploitation
type of movies right as well which uh
growing up for the summers in
mississippi you know visiting my dad i
don't remember any moonshine i i don't
really buy it even not in the 70s the
move okay the setup in this movie is
this
bart reynolds plays an inmate
he's uh
i think he's done four years
he's only got a year left on his
sentence
and somewhere out in the bayou some
this uh bad cops execute some guys they
shoot him while they're
tied to weights
in in the dam well no they he had him
tied to a bunch of cinder blocks in a in
a canoe and they shot the canoe and sank
yeah all right which was supposedly
drowned these guys well one of those
guys was burt reynolds brother younger
brother he's like a teenager like it is
i guess he's college age yeah i'm
calling him burt reynolds brother of
course you know bertha reynolds is
playing
a character named gator mcklinski
mccluskey yeah gator mccluskey
and uh
the feds approach him and they say look
we've been trying to get this uh
bad cop who owns the whole damn county
and uh he just killed your brother if
you can help us get the dirt on the guy
we'll let you out a little bit early
and go down there and
get the proof we need
and uh we'll lock him up if you testify
so mccluskey or gator gets released
early from prison
and they put him on a damn secret agent
mission from the feds to get the dirt on
this cop and of course this
gator's family [ __ ] is totally
opposed to it why the hell are you going
after bootleggers why the hell you
betraying your people helping the feds
well because his dad is a moonshiner
like well that's what that's why burt
reynolds was in prison for moonshining
because that was like a family business
yeah and this is a lot a lot of accuracy
in this movie you know it was made for
southerners by southerners for the
southern market
um
and that attitude was a reality in the
south
uh
a lot of south did consider itself to be
on friendly basis with the federal
authorities
now
the thing with
the thing with bootlegging now they they
kind of
in the movie in the as the story unfolds
the explanation for why bootlegging and
making moonshine was so important to the
south supposedly
was that
you could get a pint
of moonshine for about the same price as
a fifth of what of whiskey
and that pineapple moonshine went a lot
further
than than the than a fifth of whiskey
and none of that money went to the feds
and it was all locally produced so
southerners
low-income southerners would rather
drink that that's what their explanation
was
well some of those counties were dry
counties too were they not so you
couldn't even get i think sometimes you
couldn't even get regular yeah but i
discussed that earlier on the show too
making a dry county you used church
groups to force it into a dry county
which would give you a monopoly on blues
that was all pre-planned and it would
also drive out political enemies you
didn't want them in your in in your town
but in your county but they still drank
and even the people that
passed those laws drank
now the thing is is that i can remember
73 74 75 up to 77 i vaguely remember it
in mississippi i don't remember anybody
drinking moonshine i remember drinking
[ __ ] like wild turkey
um
i kind of think the uh the the
bootlegging moonshine aspect and a lot
of these southern exploitation movies
was kind of more of a something left
over from the 30s and the 20s
well the thing about it though it's
probably i'm sure you know people did it
but i don't think it was as widespread
as they showed in the movies but see the
thing about making moonshine
is that you still have and you kind of
see it in this movie too is that you can
still have your heroes like people
you're supposed to be rooting for doing
that even though technically it's
illegal right so they're criminals but
you're just kind of like it's just booze
it's like so you can still be doing
illegal [ __ ] without being unsympathetic
that's right thank you i think that's
kind of why it's more of a plot device i
think like i said that's why in smoking
the bandit all they were doing was
taking beer like you know across the you
know across the mississippi river which
you weren't technically supposed to do
but
it wasn't like that yes technically it
was illegal but it wasn't no one would
really see it as that big a deal right
so you could still kind of see him as
these rebellious kind of not criminals
when in reality with the money and the
money on the line and the profits they
were talking about you couldn't achieve
that with with beer or booze it would
have been weed at least
but they can't put that in the movie
yeah i can't put that in the movie but
in reality it would have been more like
something like weed
murder hornet says my brother in florida
makes his own cinnamon moonshine it
tastes pretty good
yeah well that's that's something else
yeah the people made alcohol in the
south but not really to sell just to
drink it because it's cheap it's cheap
to make your own moonshine type alcohol
and you make that on the kitchen stove
you know just out of sugar water and
stuff distilled
things and
potato peels or whatever big fat make
vodka
so
but they weren't selling it i don't
think they're just putting it in jars
and drinking it or maybe like giving it
to their friends
a couple of friends
because i kind of feel like in this
movie and i'm not saying it didn't
happen i'm just saying it might not have
been as widespread and like i said this
movie was set in arkansas
and uh in this he kind of almost has to
go
undercover and like infiltrate this
whole
network yeah and like one of the guys
has like kind of a big operation he has
like 20 dudes like working for him like
running the moonshine yeah to various
places now i remember seeing moonshine
in mississippi in the 80s it was always
in them jars
you know mason jars
but it wasn't something sold it was just
got gifts
yeah and it was uh
kind of like uh
uh what would be a home brew
and it would be like family versions of
it and it'd all be flavored and they
poured into things like hawaiian punch
yeah and you know well people do it a
lot nowadays making their own crafts
yeah right you don't really run into
problems unless you're trying to like
you know sell it sell it or run a bad
[ __ ] out of it right i mean obviously
if you're just making it for yourself
and your friends i don't know yeah
anyone's going to get it even in the 80s
the demand wouldn't have been there to
make an empire because [ __ ] man they
were drinking
wild turkey and
dolls special kinds of damn jack daniels
and you know southerners had money they
just [ __ ] went down to the grocery
store liquor store
you know
but yeah so that's kind of where so
basically he has to go in and like i
said he
he doesn't know any of these guys but
when he's kind of doing his
investigation
he's not well he knows who killed his
brother but he's trying to get
evidence
because the you know the feds they want
evidence against this corrupt cop who's
played by ned beatty by the way ned
beatty i'm sure he's played a villain in
other movies but this was maybe this is
the only movie that i can remember him
playing a villain in and he plays
actually a really good villain yeah this
is one of the best roles i've seen him
in yeah he was actually really good he's
actually kind of intimidating as a cop
and usually he plays a clown yeah you
know like the superman that's true you
know but no he [ __ ] kind of
intimidating
southern cop
police chief fat but he had a whole
bunch of [ __ ] jokers working for him
well i mean they were murderers well i
mean yeah
and there's i mean they then i think
that was a really good opening scene
because they establish it right away
where it's like ned beatty and his like
other cop buddy and they're just taking
these two teenagers essentially yeah out
in this canoe and they're all tied up
and like tied to a [ __ ] cinder block
and they're just like and they just
shoot them and just sail off by yeah
yeah those kind of funny things about
that scene is that they shoot the damn
canoe and they show the canoe sinking
with the guys in it and then it stops
for a second it cuts away i was like
well yeah because that's how deep it is
it's only like three and a half feet
deep where they shot them
you could just tell by the trees that
the bayou is not deep although if you
were tied up and couldn't get away you
might still get eaten by alligators so
there's water would have
because they were on the chairs
and then um
but what i did like about is even even
the uh
even the villain character the the
police chief
they kind of show his motivation he he's
doing the wrong thing
and but he's surrounded by some people
that are trying to snap him back into
reality like you can't make
you can't be like it was
they told him that several times
he's trying to make the south go back
to what it was
you know in the early nineteen hundreds
and no what that that that world wasn't
coming back
and
there were southerners that [ __ ]
wanted it to my grandparents were like
that my grandmother [ __ ] wanted 1920
back
yeah which is weird well yeah a lot of
people are our grandparents age dead yep
and everything was from the 1920s 1930s
viewpoint which got old man
well yeah because they were [ __ ]
rigid it was their way or the highway
there was no wiggle room
with anything yeah you remember that
remember how they were real [ __ ]
remember and i tell you what they had
[ __ ] strong willpower
they didn't really have good ideas but
[ __ ] they stuck to them
well they couldn't really think of
anything else to do like you said they
were very
real rigid right they were just kind of
like well this is the way to do things
and yeah still i thought there was only
one way to do that yes and this is the
way you have it this way and if it's not
like this and he gets into it this cop
thinks he's convinced
that these college kids are cut part of
a communist insurgency
these kids well see now i really like
that because i like that even some of
the like good guy characters and this is
there was a very prevalent um attitude
in the south because i remember my
grandparents and you know people there
yeah where they thought just like you
know uh
college students that were protesting
you know against vietnam or you know for
pot legalization or whatever um which
was kind of more the thing in this movie
because there was kind of some legalized
pot type stuff
and which nowadays is not controversial
but back then was like a really big de
facto they're not enforcing anything
anymore and yeah so so back then so even
like a lot of the good guy characters in
this like the sympathetic character like
ah goddamn hippies even though they were
doing literally nothing and then
actually you find out later
because burt reynolds character is kind
of like that too but then he finds out
like his brother his younger brother was
kind of like that was like protesting
and that was ended up it kind of ends up
that that's
contributed to what got him killed not
so much it didn't have anything to do
with the moonshining or doing anything
illegal
um it was just like the cop being a
[ __ ] and not having a protest yeah
and not liking college students or not
liking you know the the protest for
whatever it was i don't even think they
said with the protest before like i said
i think it was pot legalization that was
because somebody drove by in a car that
said something about legalized pot and
um that's right and this and then the
cop mentioned well [ __ ] if they
legalized that all our [ __ ] profits
for the moonshot would go away right so
they weren't even they didn't even like
wade into like the vietnam war quagmire
or anything like that um they were
talking about pot legalization which
like i said is really funny
nowadays but yeah he was worried about
pot legalization i guess because it
would cut into his profits because
the corrupt cop was taking money from
the moonshiners
too
so he thought it was going to cut into
his profit margin so
to him these college students were like
a direct were directly threatening his
livelihood i guess he saw it that way
another accuracy i liked in the movie is
that
that gator and his friends that
generation
were almost kind of feral they were kind
of had half of their
foot in the old south and the other half
of their foot in the new world they
really didn't believe too much of either
side they were kind of
when you see the movie you'll see what
i'm talking about um they were kind of
caught in between two worlds and my dad
and his friends were exactly like that
um
like they weren't religious they were
wild uh they they weren't hippies but
there was a lot of like sexual
liberation
uh they
weren't
violent but
like they weren't bad guys but they
would not but they would fight you know
what i mean um
you'll see you'll see what i'm talking
about this you know what i mean like
they didn't
they weren't malevolent guys
but if you felt if they felt they were
disrespected they they would defend
themselves from it
um
they were just trying to make sense of a
[ __ ] south that was changing
which i kind of liked that generation
they were a lot better than my
grandparents generation down there they
were kind of more like the sheriff in
this story real [ __ ]
hard-headed in
their way or the highway almost kind of
let's go back to 1920
and it's just not possible and as i said
most of the characters in this the
southerners and stuff are actually
portrayed as like just good-hearted
people trying to like make a buck
uh whereas the cop is kind of and the
cop even has like uh you know other cops
that are like telling him hey man you
can't keep doing this yeah you know what
you're doing is wrong
so he was kind of clearly portrayed as
the villain i think he was actually
based on a real guy yeah
another thing i liked about the movie is
that there's a lot of black people in
the movie
and they're watching the movie being
filmed
but it fits the car chase is going goes
down through the [ __ ] black
neighborhood and they're all sitting
outside watching them watching them
watching why wouldn't you white folks
make this [ __ ] movie and then where
look at this and that that's accurate
wherever you would go there'd be little
black kids running around and there's
one scene where some black kid runs up
and [ __ ]
uh gator's doing something he looks down
this little black kid just sitting there
drinking coca-cola looking at him and
[ __ ] there's like they have like this
moment where
he's realizing that there's two
different worlds gators reality and the
the reality of these little black kids
is two different realities
um
you'll see the movie you'll see what i'm
talking about when the movie and uh
living in the south of that era even up
into the 80s it was it was like that
still you'd run into little black kids
and they were almost kind of like they
were from another country still it was
weird because there was no internet no
common culture there was a white culture
and a black culture it was very separate
well as i said i think it's i mean it's
kind of subtle but they do kind of have
gator having like a little bit of a
character arc
not maybe just with about that like i
said that's pretty subtle but
him kind of coming to terms with the
fact that
he and actually at the end he realizes
that he actually like admired his
younger brother the one that was
murdered for
going to college and trying to like make
something better himself and standing up
for something that he believed in and
gators like i've just been a criminal my
whole life i never did that yeah so him
coming to terms with the fact that hey
maybe hippies maybe certain hippies
don't suck as much as like or maybe
everyone thinks they did or you know or
maybe they had some good ideas or yeah
he was saying there was something to it
yeah saying that there was something to
it you shouldn't reject everything that
they're saying
it was
uh gator is trying to gator's a centrist
and a realist that's that's more what it
is he's not poo poo in anything he's
just
taking good things from
good ideas from where they are and
throwing away bad ideas where they are
you know grantham says every time i've
had homemade beer wine it tastes like it
was made in the garbage can
yeah you got to do it right steve's beer
is [ __ ] great though what are you
talking about i don't think i've ever
had homie i made ginger beer a few times
and it was all right it just it wasn't
all that great um so much easier to make
with shine because it's just [ __ ] 190
proof alco pure alcohol
you can flavor it afterwards
gram there's also says ned beatty once
said the mail on mail rape scene and
deliverance led to years of being
shunned in hollywood i kind of heard
that too that's really weird because
it's just like a movie yeah um
but it just goes to show that back then
people are still really uncomfortable
with that yeah um you know what i mean
his career
well yeah well
maybe probably slowed it down quite a
bit yeah yeah
i mean i wonder did he know the extent
of it yeah i don't think so i mean maybe
yeah i guess it wouldn't really occur to
you because it was a good role otherwise
and like i said you have to i mean the
balls of somebody that would be in a
role like that especially back then and
i think this is after that role isn't it
uh when was when did delivery this is 73
deliverance was 72 was it not i think it
was oh it might have been it's a totally
different role he's an intimidating dude
in this which is kind of crazy because
yeah it's almost kind of like a polar
opposite
of uh of the role that he played in in
that
grand there's also says why are
southerners so tied to the past much of
which is indefensible on so many levels
honestly i don't really know why anyone
is tied to the past um
it's gone now and who's saying this grab
theirs oh
it depends on what what it is you're
talking about there isn't one pass there
was a bunch of them
depending on who you were what counter
you were in none of it was unified it
was all
chaos
um it was an agregarian society
almost organized along the lines of say
like uh
japanese feudalism it was it was like
that uh plantations and poor people had
nothing in common with each other
plantation owners were mostly originally
from the south and they would move in
and they would displace all the normal
[ __ ] farmers and all the
uh using slave labor
most of the south was against slavery uh
it was just that when a plantation would
plantations would take over a damn
uh
uh county and just run it like a like a
feudal fiefdom
it was
just k like for instance i think uh
mississippi probably had the most slaves
in general
over the time
but half of it half a damn mississippi
counties abandoned
so it was never unified it was never an
agreement on anything
it was just kind of like a frontier
place
where you could run in there and if you
had enough force and enough money and
enough guns you could just do whatever
you wanted
and
corruption lots and lots of corruption
but it's not that was not the modern
world if you looked at the population it
was sparsely populated it wasn't very
many people and they were spread out
just
that's just the way it was thank you
david june for the super chat and then
gramsci also said there's a 1980s movie
called southern comfort yeah i've seen
that with uh powers booth and david
carradine yeah about a bunch of
moonshiners capturing a national guard
unit out in the swamps it's free on
youtube yeah we might have to do i
remember that being really good i saw
that like a while back uh tammy also
says the movie lawless based on real
moonshiners in virginia very good tom
hardy movie yeah i think you guys like
recommended that one before because i
wrote it down
um let's see small town wiping okay when
i lived in uh
grandpa said when i lived in north
carolina i saw more overt racism and
open affection between whites and blacks
yeah it's a little bit uh schizo
and uh can we talk about
the
ladies in this diane ladd is in this
this might have been her first movie
although they spelled her name wrong on
the uh on the uh credits
she plays
dude's wife mom i can't remember now
uh but there is one woman in here that
is
uh the one guy's girlfriend yeah she's
the best and for sugar pudding i need
sugar pudding
she's lou but for a long time i didn't
know what her name was because her
boyfriend just kept calling her sugar
pudding all the time
that was like so funny she was like i
think she was my favorite character
sugar pudding was like one of the most
accurate
retro
characters in this
yeah that that you
you'd see that in mississippi a lot and
sugar putin would have been about
[ __ ] 13 or 14 in real life though but
she talks about what she was like at
nine so
yeah that's
yeah cause man
she's uh she's with this the guy that uh
that burt reynolds character kind of
takes up with to start the moonshine and
yeah and uh sugar pudding i guess isn't
getting enough from her boyfriend so
she's just kind of like oh look at burt
reynolds so she just like not even kind
of shamelessly right flirting and not
even flirting i mean
all but jumping right on the d it's very
very funny yeah the south
[Laughter]
the south like i said it was almost kind
of like a like a feudal system it was
kind of like feudal japan it had a class
it kind of had class stratification
and
descendants of sharecroppers and very
poor sharecroppers they've been around
for centuries down there the poor people
of the south they were tended to be
scots irish
mixed with german and maybe some native
american which that's exactly what burt
reynolds is okay jenny's part native
american she fits that same
kind of mix it's very southern
occasional spanish bloodlines
but with the poor sharecroppers
chastity and morality is the
traditional christian morality was not a
a thing they were they were almost kind
of like feral
they did whatever they wanted to do
um they weren't criminal they just were
kind of like something out of
out of a tribal community
um the women were did whatever they
wanted to do
they didn't have to be upright and
[ __ ]
chased or anything that was for rich
people
you know
a lot of times they go to church just to
pretend that they were uptight but
that's not who they were
but
i remember
girls like this
grew up with them
grandpa says i'm gonna warn my daughter
that if she ever has a boyfriend who
calls her sugar pudding let me know and
i'll get a 9 millimeter shovel
[Laughter]
yeah it really does because for a long
time like i said i wasn't sure i was
like is her name sugar pudding because
they just kept calling her that's her
nickname
i know but i mean well okay the thing
about it is that i thought that it was
just like her boyfriend calling her that
like is a term of endearment but a lot
of times like if you have a term of
endearment for somebody you don't call
them the same one all the time they were
calling her that like that was her name
who's her nickname and i was just kind
of like is that her actual name i was
like this is the south um it wouldn't
shock me all that much if some parents
had actually named their baby sugar
pudding yeah
sugar pudding was the best one of the
best characters in the movie i was she
was my favorite yeah sugar pudding was
very honest
well he ain't watching
and she's like in the car like sitting
in between the two of them and she's
like totally not even like yeah but her
boyfriend's so clueless he's just like
dude like looking out the window and
she's like hey
like sticking her tongue and burnt
rental deer and children she's talking
to you not like that she wears shoes and
when she's talking to you she just put
her feet up on your shoulder just
rubbing your face
and that's yeah
yeah walk around [ __ ] dirty feet and
[ __ ] yeah she really she did really did
have some dirty ass feet in this movie
because she was like running around
outside with no shoes on and stuff like
that she was cute though that's why she
was sugarfoot
it was just like so funny the way it was
like that whole situation although they
had the damn conflict over in the store
and the way that [ __ ] was resolved is
[ __ ] perfect and i think you had even
had a female witness go yep
yeah you won you just got to see the
moon understand
yeah it really does honestly it's funny
because this movie it's it's not like a
comedy the way smokey and the band it is
it's actually pretty serious yeah but it
did have like just some funny i mean
actually burt reynolds was
was actually pretty serious in this
because you know his brother was dead
and got murdered and he was like pissed
off about it and so it was like a
serious role it wasn't like where he was
just all jokey and sarcastic and [ __ ] a
lot of car chases lots of a lot of car
wrecks uh stunts ramps uh dukes of
hazard type [ __ ] you can see where they
got a lot of that stuff uh to me this is
almost like a very accurate
portrayal of the south of the 70s
slightly stylized and glorified by
southerners for southerners it's it's
very fair
about the way it was
um but it also very entertaining
and uh kind of like a deep south version
of mad max in a certain way along that
mad max's post-apocalyptic [ __ ] the
south has been post-apocalyptic since
the civil war
all right the south was destroyed during
the civil war basically if you read the
history he burned most of the cities
down [ __ ] they [ __ ] everything up
reconstruction [ __ ] was terrible and
then it immediately plunged into a damn
race war
you know so it was like
back olympia i kind of picture i mean
movies like this um and if you read the
wikipedia page on it like burt reynolds
was even saying that it's like you know
a lot of these types of movies uh
because he did several of these and the
producers that did this movie like made
a whole bunch of them
um was that these were specifically made
you know in the south and they were made
for southern audiences and they said
basically we'd show them in the theater
and they didn't even they didn't cost
that much to make so you didn't even
have to necessarily like show them
anywhere else in the country they did
but you didn't have to you'd still make
your money back just because they said
they could make all their money back
just on
um uh what was not nashville was it was
it memphis memphis
ticket sales in memphis was enough to
make all their money back anything out
of that outside that was all gravy so
these were like
very profitable well because as i said
it's it's just like any sub genre it's
like southerners probably wanted to see
their own lives up on screen
and you know southern working class uh
because she didn't really see that in a
lot of movies you still don't um and
honestly even movies that are i guess
it's a little bit better nowadays it's a
little more realistic but for a while i
kind of feel like there was a time
maybe i'm thinking about the 80s
where
they would show some quote unquote
working class characters and i'd be like
um
they look pretty upper middle class to
me i was like that's not real working
class right um you'd have to see some
like pretty grungy like indie movies to
see actual working-class people in
movies they would you know it's i used
to say like in in 80s movies they would
say somebody that had a job that doesn't
pay all that much and they lived alone
and they lived in this really big like
really nice apartment i'm like yeah in
no universe would that happen um but you
know so i think that's maybe part of the
appeal was that this felt to me even
though it's arkansas and i grew up in
florida
but
it looked similar i mean the
working-class areas the rural areas look
very similar
uh you still have that kind of swampy
type of [ __ ] going on and the way people
lived was very similar and like i said i
bet people liked you know people that
lived like that were kind of like jazz
to see
people like them on that screen yeah a
good a good example was is that this is
this would be the white southern version
of a rudy ray more flick like dolomite
even though those were comedies
this is more like an action movie still
the same thing action movie drama i
guess that's right still the same thing
this was
you had rudy ray moore was black product
this is more like southern product
that's that's that's the uh a good
description of it
but uh anybody could would enjoy
watching these the north south black
white whatever this these they're great
movies fun
the budget was not big but but the
quality of the production was good and
the acting was real good the writing
what makes it good was the writing the
writing was pretty good
uh some of the
some of the car chases would be kind of
passe by today's standards they weren't
to say as fantastic as as mad max won
all right or you know like uh [ __ ] uh
bullet they're not that good
but
not bad for the budget can i just say i
love the scene
where there's because there's several
car chases in this
um because it's similar to you know
where he has like they're running
moonshine and he has like somebody that
is you know kind of driving in front of
him and like you know
distracting the cops or whatever and so
he's got i don't remember what kind of
car it was
but burt reynolds drives this car like
kind of off this ramp and on to
like a flat ferry
remember that scene and like the car it
doesn't go all the way on
it just kind of
like the back yeah and i was just kind
of like and then like later they show up
like go to the mechanic and be like what
the [ __ ] did you do the undercarriage
and he's just kind of like yeah he
crawled you could tell it was a real
stunt it was a real stun it didn't quite
stick the landing he crawls out of the
damn driver's side window gets on the
hood before the car falls off the
barge it never does but it looks like it
looks like it's going at any minute
um
it's good
another thing that i thought was really
cool is that
gator
he gets into a jam eventually i mean
he's supposed to be getting dirt on
these bad cops you know and he's
supposed to he's going to have
testify against him you know in a
federal court
and uh he gets into this [ __ ]
position like you know
he may have to kill some of these cops
should he do it and uh
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah it gets it
they got that bad where he didn't have a
choice
pretty much well and he was kind of
getting it for both ends because then
like the moonshiners
they got pissed because they found out
that he was not a rat gun a rat yeah you
know even though he didn't necessarily
want to rat on them he was just trying
to get that one cop like that because
that cop killed his brother but the
moonshiners didn't see it like that they
just said well you're working undercover
for the feds and you're gonna expose us
and we don't want them so he was kind of
getting [ __ ] on from both sides so yeah
he so he got like more and more into a
jam like and he had friends that like
turned against him when you know when
they found out
but they said that was that whole thing
what's okay the only criticism i have of
this is that i thought the end which i'm
not i don't want to spoil the end but
the end i thought was a little abrupt
considering yeah i thought that they
should have like
made it like a bigger
deal should have had more of like a
grand finale but you can tell that it
was a limited budget
now i've heard that that gator the the
uh
the second movie is better it has a
bigger budget i don't know yet yeah i've
seen it but it was so long ago that i
mean i must have probably been like 12
when i saw it we'll watch that one too
i'm just going to reserve comment on it
because we haven't seen it but uh
supposedly supposedly the second one's
even better
but we'll see
i will say i was kind of curious like
the guy that directed this joseph
sargent
i wanted to see what else he had done
because i think he had worked with burt
reynolds before burt reynolds was
actually in another movie called sam
whiskey like back in 1969 which i think
is where they got the idea to cast him
in this
but i found out that the same director
that did this this is how the small
world it is also directed that horror
anthology nightmares from 1983 the one
with emilio estevez and the bishop of
battle and all that kind of stuff which
actually i've been wanting to rewatch he
also directed colossus the forbidden
project the taking of pelham three and
jaws the revenge the one with michael
kane the terrible one but um
well it's so bad it's good i saw that in
the theater but yeah it was like the
same director
but uh yeah i mean
[ __ ] if you like southern stuff like i
said we'll probably be watching gator as
well we were gonna do like i said we
were trying to watch cannonball run last
night because we were gonna do that for
tomorrow
but
we couldn't find it on streaming they
have cannonball run two everywhere but
not the first one somebody put it out
put it up on youtube like in
so
you know we didn't really want to sit
through it
uh so i don't know so actually for
tomorrow
do you want to do um that christopher
lee that german christopher lee movie we
watched we can talk about that tomorrow
yeah all right that was a weird flick
what was it called uh [ __ ] the torture
the torture chamber of doctor sadism
yeah dr sadism yeah i think that was
just like i think that was just the us
or the uk title i think the german title
was something else yeah
yeah graham says that burt reynolds was
a serious action star before he became a
parody in the 1980s yeah
smokey and the bandit i think in
cannonball run i think kinda they were
those are fun movies but they kind of
more turned him into like a clown yeah
and i think that was probably the end of
him as a as a serious actor but you know
what he was
getting on
in the in age
at the time when all that was happening
so maybe that was his best way out
to get out of the action
leading man role
uh when you see him here in white
lightning he's still pretty much in his
prime you see why he was a yeah he's
he's pretty young in this yeah he's
pretty young and um he's he's kind of in
his best form in this movie that i've
seen him in so
he made he makes a lot more sense he
kind of plays the same character through
every time you see him in the movies
he's almost kind of like playing himself
yeah i mean but that can work defending
now some people say well he's not a real
southerner he's from michigan
[Laughter]
he was he's southern
he was born in michigan because his dad
was in the army at the time and
stationed up there
but his dad his family was from georgia
after the army uh he and his his dad
moved the family
i think it was to florida and he was
he's from central here in central
florida so this is also a florida movie
his dad was the chief of police of one
of these counties around here one of
these cities i forgot which one it was
fort wayne i think no no that's indiana
fort no what fort
it's one of the forts
it's here
here in here in florida well well yeah
well you went to isn't that where you
went to uh on your little vacation
no that was saint augustine saint
augustine maybe that's where it was it
sounded familiar i thought it was fort
that was something or other though but
uh
yeah reynolds what fort myers was it
might have been fort myers myers i think
i think it's what it was um it was
his uh his dad was chief of police of
one of those cities i think was fort
myers maybe
it's probably on wikipedia you guys can
see it granters also says one of ned
beatty's last movies was charlie
wilson's war that was actually a really
great uh movie i saw in the theater he
played a congressman who funded the
taliban fighting the soviets in
afghanistan highly recommend it yeah
that was a great movie like i said i saw
in the theater when it came out yeah you
see redeemed himself in boogie nights
yeah he redeemed himself and boogie
nicely he's playing a much older role
and that's not what he would normally
played god damn it i love boogie nights
yeah that was a great movie i love
boogie nights he uh
reynolds was cool i mean yeah i don't
agree with all of his face lifts
some of them face ups didn't work out
it's his face it's his face you know
um i don't if people want to do whatever
they want with it that's like that's
that's fine i'm not uh
he had many of them and some of them
some of them looked better than others
uh he eventually did kind of settle down
to where yeah that that looks pretty
good uh but i haven't seen him recently
but that first facelift he got looked
ridiculous
yeah i'd have got my money back on yeah
grampar says bert is the pride of
lansing michigan
[Laughter]
he was born there but he was yeah but he
wasn't he wasn't from michigan
well i know but you know how everybody
from you're trying to claim that
[ __ ] sure because anybody is
from georgia
anybody that's famous they're going to
be like hey that person was born here
went to high school here or whatever
he he basically grew up in florida
do you know that the guy that played um
lurch
on the at on the original adams family
used to be
um a lifeguard on daytona beach i think
yeah like way back in the old days i
think he might have even gone to high
school in dayton he might have gone to
mainland if i'm remembering it correctly
i think somebody told me that but i just
can't remember
uh danny rowling says his face had more
lifts than tom cruise's shoes yeah
cheryl asks have you reviewed boogie
nights yeah we did yeah uh it was a
while back it was probably like a year
or more ago but uh yeah so um i guess
that'll do it for yeah so white
lightning it's on amazon prime i think
uh if i'm not mistaken i think it's also
on tubey for free if you don't have
amazon prime uh i'm not sure about gator
we'll have to look that up because
that's like the sequel to this i guess
or whatever with the same character
so uh so we'll see about that but like i
said tomorrow we will probably talk
we're going out tonight so
yeah
tonight's the last uh memento mori
because uh barbarella's moving yeah so
we don't know when they're gonna redo
memento mori like we don't know
where they're gonna move it to uh so
we'll see but this will be the last one
so we gotta go to it and uh so tomorrow
we'll probably talk about
uh
what did i say it was called the
[ __ ] man the torture chamber of dr
sadism that's what it's called right
yeah it's like a german movie and
christopher lee was in it for like 10
minutes or something but it was it was
all right it was it was nice to look at
i thought it was it was kind of fun so
yeah and the the lady that was in it
looked almost exactly like barbara
steele but it was not barbra steel
uh you should do a ted cassidy tribute
vid
yeah we probably should i mean i was a
big fan of his but uh yeah so uh anyway
thanks for dropping by on our part
reynolds day
and we will be back uh tomorrow
afternoon talking about a different
movie so thanks everybody
bye